le chemin est long et difficile, je sais.
Viens mon amour viens,
la voie est libre,
je t'attendrai dans le Tennessee.
Viens mon amour viens,
la route est calme,
le chemin est long et difficile, je sais.
Viens mon amour viens,
la voie est libre,
je t'attendrai dans le Tennessee.
Oh,
oh,
oh.
Whoa... oh je t'attendrai.
Je t'attendrai.
Je t'attendrai
je t'attendrai.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Dans l’obscurité, il vous faut la lumière.
Dans la communauté afro-américaine,
depuis des centaines d'années, c'est notre tâche
de trouver comment nous relever.
Je vais terminer avec deux morceaux de Sœur Rosetta Tharpe,
une personnalité influente de la musique américaine
dont vous n'avez pas dû entendre parler.
Si c'est le cas, je suis contente.
C'est une innovatrice de la guitare rock 'n' roll
et est parmi les premiers artistes à mélanger gospel et séculaire.
C'est une personnalité très importante
j'en parlerai à chaque fois que je le pourrai.
Voici deux de ses morceaux.
Pas d'inquiétude, vous aurez l'occasion de chanter.
(Musique)
(Chante) Considère, considère
ce chemin solitaire
avant de continuer à voyager.
Lève les yeux, lève les yeux
et salue ton créateur,
car Gabriel fait sonner son cor.
Las de porter tant de poids,
marchant sur ce chemin solitaire.
Considère ce chemin solitaire,
avant de continuer à voyager.
Considère, considère
ce chemin solitaire
avant de continuer à voyager.
Lève les yeux, lève les yeux
et salue ton créateur,
car Gabriel fait sonner son cor.
Las de porter tant de poids,
marchant sur ce chemin solitaire.
Considère, considère, considère, considère
ce chemin solitaire
avant de continuer à voyager.
Au-dessus de ma tête,
au-dessus de ma tête,
j'entends de la musique
j'entends de la musique.
Au-dessus de ma tête
au-dessus de ma tête
j'entends de la musique
j'entends de la musique.
Au-dessus de ma tête
au-dessus de ma tête
j'entends de la musique
de la musique
et je crois vraiment
qu'il y a un Paradis quelque part.
Au-dessus de ma tête
au-dessus de ma tête
j'entends chanter
chanter.
Au-dessus de ma tête
au-dessus de ma tête
j'entends chanter
j'entends chanter.
Au-dessus de ma tête
au-dessus de ma tête
j'entends chanter
chanter
et je crois vraiment
je crois vraiment
qu'il y a un Paradis.
(Parle) Maintenant, guitare !
(Guitare)
Voici Hubby Jenkins.
(Chante) Au-dessus de ma tête
au-dessus de ma tête
j'entends crier
crier.
Au-dessus de ma tête
au-dessus de ma tête
j'entends crier
j'entends crier.
Au-dessus de ma tête
au-dessus de ma tête
j'entends crier, c'est vrai,
et je crois vraiment je crois vraiment
qu'il y a un Paradis.
(Parle) Allez maintenant, donne-moi un peu de contrebasse.
(Solo de contrebasse)
Ouais !
Woo !
Jason Sypher à la contrebasse.
Jamie Dick à la batterie.
Allez maintenant,
il me reste peu de temps.
Il est temps pour vous de chanter.
Sous forme d'appel et réponse.
J'appelle, vous répondez.
Il y a beaucoup de chansons comme ça, vous savez comment ça marche.
Vous allez chanter ?
J'ai dit, vous allez chanter ?
Public : Oui !
Rhiannon Giddens : C'est parti !
(Chante) Au-dessus de ma tête
P : au-dessus de ma tête
RG : de la musique
P : de la musique
RG : au-dessus de ma tête
P : au-dessus de ma tête
RG : de la musique
P : de la musique
RG : au-dessus de ma tête
P : au-dessus de ma tête
RG : de la musique
P : de la musique
RG : et je crois vraiment je crois vraiment
qu'il y a un Paradis.
Encore une fois !
Au-dessus de ma tête
P : au-dessus de ma tête
RG : j'entends de la musique
P : de la musique.
RG : Au-dessus de ma tête
P : au-dessus de ma tête
RG : j'entends de la musique
P : de la musique.
RG : Au-dessus de ma tête
P : au-dessus de ma tête
RG : j'entends de la musique
P : de la musique
RG : et je crois vraiment je crois vraiment
qu'il y a un Paradis.
J'ai dit je crois vraiment je crois vraiment
Un Paradis.
(Tient la note)
(Applaudissements) (Encouragements)
(Fin de la musique)
(Applaudissements)